this video is brought to you by swedish
pod 101 pod 101 courses are one of my
favorite ways to start learning a new
language online click the link in the
description for a free lifetime account
to give it a try
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul in the
recent video on the swedish language we
focused on the history of swedish as
well as some of its major features but
swedish is also an incredibly expressive
language with colorful slang expressions
and idioms today we're going to focus on
some common slang and then we're going
to look at some widely used idioms
meaning bro or brother the main word for
brother is rur from which this is
obviously derived
what's happening
another common expression is
meaning what's up well it literally
means what is being done
this is like what's happening bro
i'm just chilling this comes from the
american english slang chill out or
chill
are you still hungover
is short for bark full which means
hungover yo
yo yo
yeah i saw you pass out on the sofa last
night
the formal meaning of
is literally deck both in the sense of a
floor and in the sense of decking
someone in other words hitting them but
in this slang usage it's an intransitive
verb like you decked on the sofa with
the meaning of you passed out this guy
should consider drinking a little bit
less
the formal word for beer in swedish is
a cognate of the english word ale
but there's also a slang word besh
it came from the phrase biased el
meaning bavarian beer which turned into
baes earl and then it was further
shortened to bash this may not be
classified as genuine slang since it's
been in use for a long time but it's at
least distinctly informal there's also
another informal word for beer
which originally came from italian
oh bro bad
in swedish
means good and oo is a negation prefix
like un in english so it's like saying
ungood in english which is not an
official english word but you could use
it in a slangy way and it would work the
swedish word is kind of like that the
formal way of saying bad is doalit or
inte bro which means not good
how's your beer
pretty bad a similar word is
cool uncool the formal way of saying it
is in the cool meaning not cool this
prefix can be added freely to lots of
different adjectives to create a new
slangy word langfocus cool pewdiepie
langfocus is uncool pewdiepie is cooler
you ain't swedish if you don't have
knicker bro that's just a fact another
word that can be used to mean cool is
fett which literally means fat in formal
swedish the
bill that's a cool car
another common slang word is this one
that means angry luck
humble
he got angry
i'm the black foreigner
he got angry because i said he was fat
but i meant it was cool
the rich guy got angry because someone
stole his champagne
this literally means griller as in
someone who grills steak but in slang it
refers to a snobby rich guy who likes to
flaunt his wealth in the bars of
stockholm these guys are famous for
panning as in panning for gold in slang
it means ordering two bottles of
champagne and dumping out the contents
of one of them just to show off how rich
they are
the good news is that people who do
stupid things like that with their money
usually don't stay rich for very long
in recent decades some slang has also
entered swedish from immigrant languages
in particular turkish but also arabic
and some others this slang is more
widely used in immigrant communities but
it's also used to a lesser extent by
young people in general
one such word is kef meaning bad the t
at the end here indicates the neuter
form
this comes from the arabic word kef or
kaif meaning pleasure or fun the meaning
became reversed from positive to
negative in swedish they kept that's bad
they are a gift
this means money and this is a loanword
from turkish
this means police this comes from
turkish inesis which means without
mirror an expression used in turkish to
refer to police in a negative way
meaning that they're shameless and can't
look at themselves in the mirror the
funny thing is that in swedish they just
say aina so they're referring to police
as mirrors rather than as people who
can't look in the mirror swedish
speakers don't only use slang they also
use lots of colorful idioms some of
which seem truly bizarre in translation
its literal translation is no danger on
the roof
it means no worries or there's nothing
to worry about
another idiom with a similar meaning is
some which literally means no cow on the
ice this is taken from a longer idiom
which literally means there is no cow on
the ice as long as the butt is still on
land
literally slide in on a shrimp sandwich
you say this when you were lucky and
something turned out to not require much
effort or work
on the other hand when you gave
something your best shot but you were
unsuccessful and it didn't turn out as
you expected you might say neuro cooked
let's cooktop stick literally now the
boiled pork is fried
some swedish idioms are similar to ones
used in english so mambeda from maliga
this literally means the way you make
your bed you have to lie in it in
english we have a similar idiom you've
made your bed now lie in it and there
are numerous variations of this idiom in
english basically it means you'll have
to live with the consequences of your
own actions
this means butterflies in the stomach
meaning something like an anxious
feeling
literally that's easy as a pancake and
it simply means that's really easy in
english we have a number of expressions
like this one of them is easy as pie
though that's a pretty outdated
expression and no one really uses it
anymore maybe that's something my
grandmother would say but another
similar expression might be it's a
cakewalk both expressions mean that
something's really easy to do
buy the pig in the bag this is similar
to the english idiom by a pig in a poke
poke meaning sac or bag in both
languages it means to buy something
without examining the item first so that
it might not be exactly what you expect
it to be it might be fake low quality or
broken etc
i'm sure i'm just barely scratching the
surface of swedish slang and idioms but
the great thing about social media is
that you can participate in the comments
so swedish speakers why don't you write
your favorite slang and idioms in the
comments down below and speakers of
other languages if you have any similar
slang or idioms in your languages you
can tell us about those too
if you're excited to learn more swedish
then click the link in the description
to visit swedish pod 101 or visit
langfocus.com
swedishpod i really recommend you check
out innovative languages courses whether
for swedish or one of the other 33
languages they offer click the link in
the description to get a free lifetime
account i also want to give a big shout
out to all the langfocus patreon
supporters especially the top tier
patrons whose names are on the screen
check out patreon.com langfocus and
check out the benefits of the various
tiers and everyone thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you